let's go through the jaguars roster
speed round style we did it yesterday
with the packers but
let's let's do we are we doing it or not
we in are we out
all right all right fast fast fast
through the jaguars roster
how do they how do they stack up against
other teams a team that was one of 15
last year yeah let's start with the
receivers dj shark marvin jones leviska
chennault
chris manhertz at tight end how do they
stack up
just loosely yeah loosely that group
right there i mean
you know again i think that's sneaky
it's got sneaky potential there dj
shark is like one of those receivers
you'd throw out there to go who's one of
the best receivers nobody knows or talks
about in football
you know so when i look at it from that
angle i go like
right around the middle of the league
that's where i kind of look at them but
the potential maybe to be
in that top third if chanal you know
and channel can kind of come through and
help them out and marvin jones of course
you know carves out a pace
place there but yeah there's uh you know
there's some potential there with this
group
i feel like they've been in that
category every year for the last five or
six years sneaky potential jaguars
receivers oh look at these guys oh dee
dee westbrook sneaky potential yeah
you're right it's gone oh sneaky
potential marquis lee now he's long gone
right sneaky potential and the guy and
whoever it is alan hearns alan robinson
they come and they go they have a big
year and then they disappear and that's
that and then it's another guy that's
got sneaky potential
yeah you're i mean it's funny when you
lay it out like that
you're right it's been a lot of that
story you know dj sharp dj shark is the
guy
he is he's got size he's got game
breaking type
speed of course we know he hasn't had
the quarterback that can really
show us or help help you know
show everybody what he's really got but
uh i i think he's one that's more than
potential like he's
he's legit he's the real deal it's the
other guys we got to see about
you know leviska chanel second year in
the nfl marvin jones banged up a little
bit year last year
with detroit what's he gonna be like but
nonetheless i think they've given
something to trevor lawrence
to make it work in the passing game and
and be dangerous that way
i i'm going to say that they are at the
top of the bottom third with the
potential to climb and it's going to
depend upon lots of other factors how
far they climb
running backs james robinson a
revelation last year
undrafted out of illinois state great
season
touchdowns yards fantasy football stud
showed up at training camp and won the
job without the benefit of a preseason
and now here comes first round pick
travis atn carlos hyde's on the team
where do those three stack up in
comparison to other running backs damn
i think when you talk about a trio you
know that's that's a potential top 10
group there i mean i think especially
when you just talk about the the duo of
robinson and atn and carlos hyde is no
joke
i mean it's a pretty damn good group all
together
robinson can do everything atn is the
same way
he can do everything too at just i think
at a higher level
and then you got carlos hyde that's a
sledgehammer and can run with
real power and be a power back that way
that's where i think you got to be
excited so i think it's like one of
those themes that's like dancing around
maybe right outside the top ten at that
position
with a chance to be like firmly in the
top ten
with the with a good year by travis atn
to add to it a thousand and seventy
rushing yards in 14 games last year
for james robinson who was the week one
starter had some injuries down the
stretch that knocked him out
the offensive lines need some work right
yes and you've got cam robinson andrew
norwell who took less money and stayed
around brandon linder at center aj can
at right guard and juwan taylor at right
tackle
where where are they yeah are they at
top half bottom half pass fail
bottom bottom average below bottom half
for sure
i mean really bottom third to really
like if you want to get into that
you know i i think i look at it and go
norwell and linder are the only ones i
look at to just consistently play
well yeah norwell's not the star he was
you know four or five years ago coming
from the carolina panthers
cam robinson hey they franchise tagging
them
he's got everything you need physically
you know juwan taylor the same thing the
guy that fell to them in the second
round two years ago in the draft
got everything you need they just they
got to put it together but that has like
got to be a better unit all together for
for trevor lawrence for that offense and
what urban meyer is going to do
yeah they're towards the bottom third of
football and and that's going to be the
key because if they aren't able to block
for trevor
lawrence or the running backs i mean
he's not going to have time to to find
open receivers
and uh it's just got to fall together
right and they better hope they can
coach those five
up to be better than individually you
would look at them and say they are
and and they stay healthy get some
continuity and consistency get an early
season schedule that maybe is conducive
to building some confidence getting some
buying they're one of the teams we
talked about this yesterday
they're definitely one of the teams
chris that needs to have a favorable
early season schedule
so urban meyer can get off to a good
start and so the players can say yeah
okay we see
yeah we buy into this right we kind of
like this and the offensive line's a big
part of it
very quickly let's just throw the whole
defense together yeah a couple of years
ago
dominant or at least on the front now
right what what are they now
now they're like just a bunch of young
guys with potential but nothing special
at all
i mean when you just you know miles jack
and joe schobert
at middle linebacker they're really good
miles jack to me is one of the better
middle linebackers in football
but a lot of everything else is young
hey caleb on chase on
can he you know become a better pass
rusher you know roy robertson harris
coming from
you know the the chicago bears they paid
a lot of money for him
can he live up to that cj henderson
their top ten pick from two years ago a
corner he was really good last year
does he continue to be awesome and then
they got some guys they drafted on
defense this this
in this past draft that i think are
going to be instant contributors so like
there's talent there but it's got to
grow
and they're definitely in the bottom
third of football as far as their
defense is concerned
just amazing when you think back to last
year they stole that game against the
colts
right the season and that was it and
then just and then it just went the
other way 15 straight losses and now a
new beginning for the jacksonville
jaguars the defense though
uh definitely needs some work and
they're just
they were three years removed from being
on the brink of the super bowl just
shows you how quickly things
can fall apart hi i'm mike tarico and
thanks for watching
make sure to hit subscribe for the
latest news and highlights
from nbc sports